U.S President Joe Biden has marked the
first anniversary of the storming of the
U.S capital when a violent mob of trump
supporters attempted to stop the
certification of the 2020 election
result and Biden's win in his speech the
president sought to lay out the truth of
what happened that day a year on many
Trump supporters continue to spread a
false narratives about the attack and
many republican lawmakers refused to
acknowledge that President Biden won the
election he said that American democracy
is under threat as long as this Discord
remains he also had a very Frank
assessment of his predecessor who he
said has set the stage for the attack by
continuously sowing doubt about the 2020
election
he's not just a former president
he's a defeated former president
to feed it by a margin of over 7 million
of your votes
Let's uh bringing DW's up Washington
Bureau chiefer innocent poll and uh
reporter William brewcroft uh both of
whom were with me here in the studio as
the events over a year ago unfolded
let's start with uh are you Enos so we
had president bideness speaking to the
nation what stood out for you
well Phil that was really a historic uh
Speech and probably the strongest so far
from President Biden and it's really
very rare to hear such a harsh and
personal uh criticism from a sitting
president about a former president I
mean he talked about his bruised ego so
uh and other things so he he was really
very outspoken and he kind of
um changed his strategy as for now we
knew him as a president who really tried
to reach out to the other side to unify
the country but with this speech he made
it Crystal Clear he has given up hope to
convince Trump's supporters that he is
the elected president he has given up
hope to convince as you just refer to
the Republican lawmakers who stand firm
behind the big lie that the election was
rigged so this was kind of really a
clear attack on all some supporters
William glucrov let's pick up that that
point about the attack
um President Biden never named Donald
Trump but he went after him time and
time again President Biden never named
Donald Trump and Steven Spielberg never
showed Jaws the show and what made it
one of the most terrifying movies of all
time and Joe Biden runs that risk of
enlarging this Boogeyman that's out
there by not but by constantly referring
to him this man behind the curtain
um
and there's a real risk there he's
walking a very fine line you can't
uh ignore the elephant in the room no
pun attendance as Republicans their icon
their mascots the elephant but when you
address it you make him more powerful
more strong remember Donald Trump is
banned from social media he's very quiet
we can't hear him right now
um and so how to address him how to talk
about him uh is a really risky move for
Joe Biden he's the president
um Joe Biden runs the risk of of
bringing himself down to the level of
Donald Trump who he himself says as a
defeated president
um and we'll have to see the days and
weeks go on as we head towards the
midterms in November how the Democrats
are going to play this because Donald
Trump is very influential is very
powerful
can't ignore that but also don't want to
give him even more power and give him
even more influence right now in his Pro
in Washington
um
lots of Republicans didn't attend this
event it happened just over an hour ago
is this is that too soon for us to
assess what sort of reaction there has
been
no it's not we hear criticism from both
sides uh predictable criticism from uh
the Republican side and from those Trump
supporters who pay attention and to be
quite Frank here that's not many because
uh it is really hard to reach them
anyhow and even a a speech from a
sitting president doesn't get a lot of
attention from that side of the
political uh party uh uh uh
party sites so to speak but Phil what I
find interesting there's also criticism
from the Democratic world because they
say as kind of a William
mentioned here that he really not only
took a risk but took it too far because
this was not a speech was which was
meant to unify this was the speech which
is polarizing and so this is really as I
said earlier a change of his strategy so
it will not go only down well he will
definitely get a lot of Applause from
Democrats but the fear is that with that
speech he kind of really
um put himself in even deeper risk to
will the mid to will to lose sorry the
midterm election this November
understood uh anus and William say with
us
um what we'll do now is we will have a
further look at the the events of the
6th of January a year ago today
long before election day Donald Trump
had announced that if he should lose the
White House then only because the
election was rigged it didn't come as a
surprise that thousands of trump
followers gathered in Washington DC the
very day the peaceful transition of
power was meant to take place January 6
in 2021 him they are here since the I
had been at the mall for hours to report
for DW news and could physically feel
how the mood changed during the speech
of Donald Trump
the protests so far had been intense but
with every sentence Donald Trump spoke
it got more and more aggressive
our country has had enough we will not
take it anymore and that's what this is
all about
no one was prepared for what happened
then neither police nor politicians the
images of trump supporters storming the
capital of the United States shocked the
world and left deep marks in this
country which claims to be one of the
oldest democracies
the findings of the investigations
showed how close a real coup d'etat was
this cold January afternoon
well um it is Paul your report there
let's let's talk about the people who
who did the storming because the idea
that the election was stolen is still
widely held there
absolutely and it seems to be impossible
to convince those people from the truth
but as President Biden himself said in
his speech this is probably
the election or the result which was
kind of checked the most in the whole
history of the country it was counted
over and over again it took days before
the official outcome was announced
because they wanted to be a crystal
clear that the that the election that
the election is legal but that doesn't
matter for those Trump supporters who
just believe that he was re-elected and
why is that Phil because uh Donald Trump
has prepared that moment it's not enough
to just think about January 6 as a
singular issue Donald Trump has prepared
that even before the election took place
that if he would lose then only because
the election would be stolen from him so
he really really prepared this moment
and his followers still do believe that
and William bluecraft Donald Trump still
the preeminent figure in the Republican
Party absolutely and all the more as
we've seen the Republican party has
become the party of trump right any any
dissenting view has been swept away
ostracized criticized
um and we see lining up for the midterms
in November mini trumps you know
so-called mini trumps these little
candidates running for for districts all
around the country getting backed by
Donald Trump using a lot of his tactics
um and Republicans who have opposed
Donald Trump getting challenged within
their own party by other candidates
now we should be clear Donald Trump has
not made any intentions known about his
thoughts for 2024 but 2022 Donald Trump
is still in a way on the ballot at least
his ideology or his um approach to
politics and as I said earlier Democrats
are going to have a real big Challenge
on how to confront that because when you
confront it you make it bigger but you
ignore it you will give it space to
metastasize and that is a huge political
problem right now in the U.S especially
in a country where you only have two
options a zero or a one a black or a
white and there's really very little in
between okay so I'm going to put the
same question to both of you uh Joe
Biden in his speech said that democracy
was attacked on on that day and the
Constitution faced the gravest of
attacks so um we'll start with you uh
William what would you how would you
assess the state of U.S democracy Now
basically what we've seen is a kind of
extremism a kind of white nationalism
that has always existed in America on
the fringes and also not not completely
on the fringes if you look through the
Civil Rights Movement if you look to the
Jim Crow era if you look to after the
Civil War when black people were were
lynched in the streets
um and the Ku Klux Klan had an extreme
amount of power in certain parts of
America but you've seen these kinds of
forces now come to the Forefront
to the very Halls of American power to
be legitimized and to not be called out
we saw this for example
um in the unite the right uh rally in
2017 when there was a far-right rally
and Donald Trump said there's good
people on both sides that's what we're
seeing now nothing new but certainly
more extreme and the same question to to
you Ina so how would you assess the
state of U.S democracy as we start the
new year
as I don't want to repeat what William
said because I totally agree on him I
want to kind of talk a little bit about
another aspect so the concern for many
is that the January 6 Insurrection has
set a precedent for for any disputed or
close election in the future many are
talking about the impact to the 2024
presidential election but I think we
really have to wonder whether the 2022
midterm election and the institutions
that kind of hold the Democratic process
together will hold firm especially with
expectations that candidates running for
offices would simply not accept the
outcome and possible putting another
dent in U.S democracy so that is
something we really have to put some
thinking in I think thank you for that
in Us in his poll in Washington William
glucrafter here with me in the studio
thank you both
well let's get some German political
reaction to that speech from Tomas
silberhorn he's a member of Germany's
opposition Christian social Union and
his parliamentary spokesperson on
transatlantic relations welcome to DW
um do those events of a year ago in
Washington have any relevance for us
here in Germany
yes of course we followed very closely
this domestic debate in the United
States also because we had an attack an
attempted attack on the German Buddhist
attack in August 2020 so half a year
earlier at the Martians of protests
against covid-19 restrictions whipped up
by right-wing next to this so we also
experienced an attack on our Parliament
and that's why these attacks at the
hearts of our democracies are attacks on
our democracies itself and that's why
this is not only a U.S debate
domestically but an international debate
and the stability of our democracies is
at stake and what was what went through
your mind when you saw that writing and
unfolding on Capitol Hill a year ago
it was unbelievable because uh there
were red lines exceeded by so many
citizens
and there is no self-empowerment in
democracy that's why we have to assure
ourselves
uh on the core values of our democracy
as it laid down in the German Anthem
this is Unity law and freedom and there
is a certain minimum consensus of
Democrats needed that there is no
self-empowerment permitted but public
institutions need to increase their
credibility again with shrinking
credibility of political actors of
journalists we have at the same time a
growing skepticism and the growing
division of our societies we are
threatened by attacks from outside our
democracies but also from inside our
societies and that's why we have to be
very aware of these threats we have to
address them publicly in public
discussions we have to increase the
transparency and the dialogue as close
to our citizens as possible but in
substance we have to strengthen our core
values Unity law and freedom so in a
world driven by a pandemic and the rise
of the the far right and people are
protesting against having their their
Liberties clamped down on albeit in a uh
in a in a good name
um you are you are you quite happy that
what happened in in the United States in
in Washington
can't happen here in Germany especially
given what what happened in in August of
uh 2020 as you mentioned
I have fully trust in the professional
work of our and your police public
prosecutors and course and of course the
parliaments we have to leave this
discussion publicly at the same time we
have to make concrete offers to our
citizens
um democracy is when you get the
government you deserve because it's your
decision so we all are part of our
Democratic order and we have to make
very clear distinctions to autocratic
orders who do not offer freedom of
speech to their citizens who do not
offer the freedoms we deserve in our
liberal orders and that's why we have to
be very clear and distinct and be aware
of uh the achievements of our liberal
office
thank you so much for joining us at
Thomas silberhorn from Germany's a
Christian social Union
thank you
for say that as many as 2500 people may
have been involved in the January 6th
attack the legal and political
consequences are far from over with a
congressional investigation underway
plus law enforcement pursuing cases
across the country Democrats are under
pressure to conclude their work before
November's midterm elections after which
they may lose control of Congress let's
bring in DW's William glucroft who has
more on this that was more thanks Sarah
yeah this is one of the largest most
complex investigations in American
history and let's have a quick look why
that is so there are two tracks here
first there is the legal the criminal
side of things and so far we're looking
at a 725 people arrested in connection
with the capital attack now some of them
have military and law enforcement
experience or belong to militias or
other far-right groups but many more are
first-time offenders who say they simply
got caught up in the chaos of the day
now around 165 guilty pleas have already
come in and 70 of them have been
sentenced many more will go on trial
starting next month and then there are
350 more suspects that federal agents
are looking for they're still at large
now not all the defendants were directly
present or actually breached the capital
and that is making for a very difficult
prosecution and a lot of disagreement
about how hard to go on those involved
it's also unclear if these
investigations will extend to big name
Media or political figures for any of
their potential involvement where might
that come in well that's the political
side of things now you might remember
Republicans rejected a broader more
formal investigation so Democrats who
control the house that's the lower House
of the legislature they establish their
own special committee to investigate the
causes and consequences of the attack
now there's a nine person panel it
includes just two Republicans and that
shows just how few Republicans are
willing to publicly cross Donald Trump
this committee has gone through a huge
amount of evidence including 300 witness
statements 30 000 records 52 subpoenas a
subpoena legally requires a person to
answer questions and if they refuse they
can be held in contempt of congress
which has so far happened to two people
both of them close Trump advisors others
are suing the committee to keep it from
getting access to documents and the
question is how much will this committee
go after high-level Trump allies or even
Donald Trump himself and what will they
do with any evidence they collect and if
Democrats lose the house in November
this committee is likely to get shut
down
but the biggest question is does any of
it matter the committee says it wants to
have high level hearings in prime time
to present its case to the public but
the house already did that when they
impeached Donald Trump for the second
time this time last year in connection
to this Insurrection and the Senate
acquitted him it didn't change public
opinion much then and that appears to
still be the case depending on the poll
or the question asked a considerable
number of Americans and sometimes
majorities of Republicans believe the
lie that the election was stolen despite
no evidence and all the evidence to the
contrary many for many fear for American
democracy or expect another mob-like
attack republican-led states have
tightened voting rights and Trump has
never been stronger in his party most of
those convicted have further involvement
in the attack are getting light
sentences like house arrest fines or
probation with just a few people facing
some jail time and that's because the
U.S doesn't know this kind of political
turmoil so coming up with the
appropriate punishment that fits the
crime is a big challenge judges disagree
about sentencing many of the individual
alleged crimes are small times era but
they add up to the most serious attack
on American democracy since the Civil
War